welcome to this short introduction to
wolfram notebooks
wolfram notebooks were first released in
1988
as the user interface for wolfram
language systems so a typical wolfram
language session might look something
like this
with inputs and outputs displayed in a
notebook window
wolf from notebooks have always been
much more than just a user interface
though
in addition to inputs and outputs the
notebook can include headings and
comments as shown here
as well as project information and
hyperlinks and anything else that you
might want to put in the document here's
a more finished notebook with notes and
tables and interactive features like
buttons and sliders
all organized into sections and
subsections
a wolfram notebook like this is uniquely
itself a programmable wolfram language
expression
it can be saved to the cloud for viewing
in a web browser
or format it as a slide presentation
or shared as a standalone electronic
document
or viewed on mobile devices and a
wolfram notebook can be created and
edited programmatically from the wolfram
language
which enables a broad range of
applications like generating rich
reports automatically
or even saving notebooks as expressions
in a blockchain for computational
contracts
creating a notebook to see a few basic
details of how
all of these features come together
consider a project that starts with an
empty notebook
this first input imports some data
related to earthquakes
and this next input organizes that data
into a data set
there are a variety of aids to help with
getting the syntax right when entering
these inputs
this next input will give a plot of the
geographic locations of earthquakes
and as this input is being entered
unmatched brackets and quote marks are
shown in a different color
and different types of keywords are
shown in different colors and for longer
programs
there are other programming aids like
automatic line breaking and so on
this shows another one of those
programming aids called command
completion which displays a menu of
choices given the first few letters in
the name of a function
and after the function is chosen you can
bring up a menu of function
templates for the arguments of the
function
this input gives a histogram of
earthquake magnitudes
before a project like this gets very far
along it can be useful to include
notes or background information to
describe say an overview of the project
or to give details about what each
calculation is doing
notes like that can be inserted by
clicking anywhere between the inputs and
outputs and entering text much as you
might do in any text editor
you can indicate that you are entering
text by choosing text from the styles
sub menu
under the format menu or by using the
equivalent keyboard shortcut
eventually the notebook can become large
enough that it is useful to add some
organization
there are several ways of doing that
here i will start by entering a title
and then a section heading at the start
of each new topic
section headings are added much like
text by clicking where you want to put a
heading
and choosing section from the styles
submenu of the format menu
or by using the equivalent keyboard
shortcut a key feature of notebooks is
that notebooks are structured documents
where everything in the notebook is
organized into units called
cells there are many different types of
cells
inputs are shown in input cells outputs
are shown in output cells
text is shown in text cells section
headings are shown in section cells
and so on cells are typically identified
by cell brackets near the right edge of
the notebook window
cells can also be nested so for example
there is a cell bracket that groups each
input
with the corresponding output and in
this notebook for each section heading
there is an outer bracket that
automatically groups the section heading
with
all of the cells in that section
returning now to the top of the notebook
one useful feature of grouped cells is
that cell groups can be opened and
closed
for example double clicking on the outer
section cell brackets in this notebook
closes the section cells to show only
the section headings
which gives this outline overview of the
notebook for many projects it is
convenient to start with an outline like
this
and then proceed with the project by
entering content within that outline
closed cells can be reopened by
double-clicking on the same cell bracket
or by clicking this icon in the heading
of the closed cell
notebooks support many other formatting
features
so far this notebook has only been shown
with the default styles
but the notebook can be displayed in a
variety of formats by choosing from
different style sheets like the ones
shown here
or by setting up your own styles another
important feature of notebooks is
support for mathematical typesetting
which is useful for projects that
involve any sort of mathematics
the default mathematical type setting
will look more like this
with slightly different typeface and
formatting which has some advantages
or there are options to make the display
look more like what you might find in a
traditional textbook
all of this is fully integrated with the
rest of the system and can be used for
input or output or anywhere else in the
notebook
you can also create tables and itemized
lists and automatic numbering and other
structures that you might expect to find
in modern typesetting systems
notebooks also support interactive
controls like buttons and sliders
here for example is a display that
provides sliders for selecting a range
of earthquake magnitudes
and buttons for selecting the year
controls like these can be used to set
up interactive documents
so that anyone using the notebook can
explore data or choose the content that
they want to see or even control
complicated calculations right from
within the notebook
as noted earlier there are a number of
ways of sharing notebooks or saving
notebooks to the cloud
under the file menu you can choose save
to cloud and then reload the notebook
from the cloud
or here i will choose publish to cloud
which saves a notebook that can be
viewed in any web browser
this shows that notebook in a web
browser where the notebook
looks and behaves much like the original
notebook including all of the
interactive features
so this is a dynamic document notebooks
can also be shared just as they are
as electronic documents and viewed using
any wolfram language system or using the
free wolf from notebook player
this shows that notebook viewed in the
wolfram player which again behaves much
like the original notebook
except for a different border around the
window with a few clicks of the mouse
this notebook can also be converted to a
slideshow with each section in a
separate slide
for this notebook that can be done by
setting the style sheet to a presenter
tools style
and then set the screen environment to
slideshow working
to access the tools for editing the
presentation
one of those tools brings up this dialog
box to get a separate slide for each
section
then click start presentation to show
the slides
all of the editing and interactive
features work in the presentation just
as they do in the original notebook
so basically wolfram notebooks provide a
system for organizing projects and
collaboration
all the way from initial concept through
to distribution of reports
or presentations or sharing in the cloud
or even as wolfram language expressions
integrated into your source code
or directly embedded as documents in
your web content
there's much more to be said about all
the features that came up in this short
video
you can find more information in online
documentation or
in other videos on wolfram notebooks
welcome to the world of wolfram
technology we hope you'll enjoy being
part of the worldwide community of
wolfram users